2022 has been another big step forward
for mobile games across iPhone and
Android as developers have used the
medium to craft unique experiences put
fresh twists on familiar genres and
improve on established games with
feature-packed upgrades so here are
gamespot's 5 best mobile games of the
year as well as 5 honorable mentions
that you can't afford to miss
foreign
[Music]
the beauty of Marvel snap is that it
intelligently streamlines the appeal of
assembling a deck of cards and seeing
how it Stacks up against an opponent a
free-to-play digital card game that
draws inspiration from the mighty Marvel
Universe Marvel snap manages to simplify
the deck building genre without feeling
like a dumbed down approach this makes
for an incredibly easy to play game one
filled with countless ways to win and
complex strategies thanks to the use of
unique zones that add a wide variety of
modifiers in any given round with a
flexible deck some quick thinking and a
little forward planning you'll soon find
yourself losing hours of your time to a
game that draws you in with its
fine-tuned mechanics and Slick
presentation the best part though each
match is a digestible showdown between
similarly matched players seldom lasting
more than a few minutes in a fast-paced
world where time is valuable Marvel snap
is a delightful distraction that's
always pushing you to try out new cards
and Tack tactics while you're on the go
in his 9 out of 10 review Steve Watts
wrote the Advent of digital collectible
card games has led to an explosion of
different approaches to the genre mostly
though new games have adapted the
fundamentals of physical ccgs with
Marvel snap Hearthstone veteran Studio's
second dinner has reduced the
collectible card game to its most
essential pieces and reimagined them
creating a combination of systems that
are elegantly simple without ever
feeling simplistic
some of the best mobile gaming
experiences come from the unlikeliest of
places and it's a good bet that few
people were expecting digital embroidery
to be as captivating as it is in Stitch
the game takes the art of embroidery and
uses it as a foundation to create a
delightful experience that plays like
picross fused together with intricate
Stitch work it is delightfully easy to
find your footing in and with Lumen
developer like Studios at the helm the
controls are easy to grasp and intuitive
but the real joy in Stitch comes from
the breathtaking attention to detail on
display every thread button and Stitch
is on Full display here and weaving them
together into a unique creation feels
blissfully relaxing as you combine your
resources to slowly transform your
canvas into a work of art while there
are tricky moments that will make you
think twice before you make your next
move Stitch feels consistently relaxing
and makes clever use of its touchscreen
controls to deliver needlework catharsis
with games like Wordle reigniting a
hunger for Pure logical fun we've seen a
rebirth in games that test your mental
might not words is a great example here
as while it may look like your standard
crossword puzzle given a new coat of
paint it manages to put a fresh spin on
one of the longest running brain teaser
activities still in print circulation
today a mix of word and logic puzzles
not words kicks the traditional
crossword clues to the curb and arranges
the available letters into a knot that
can then form valid words it's a
deceptively simple formula during the
first few games that grows devilishly
more challenging the more you play and
are forced to shake your brain for the
right answers it's essentially a more
complex game for anyone that finds word
or too simple for their tastes and with
an eye-catching design a generous number
of puzzles to work through and an extra
challenging mode for anyone looking to
spend all day staring at their screen
while every Cog in their head turns not
words is a terrific Whetstone to sharpen
your mind with
imagine if Pacific Rim met chess and
you'd have a good idea of what to expect
from into the breach one of the best
games on PC since its release back in
2018 into the breach finally made its
long-awaited debut on mobile this year
with an advanced Edition that throws an
entire timeline's worth of extra content
into the originals mechanized frame it's
still an elegant game of tactical
positioning situational awareness and
making some very hard decisions In the
Heat of battle but enhanced with
thoughtful tweaks and additional content
that deepens an already thrilling
experience the sheer Joy of canceling
the apocalypse with a rocket-propelled
fist or lining up Kaiju in a row before
you atomize them with a laser is still
there but the options for a deeper
strategic experience one with new squads
Pilots abilities and modes is on Full
display with this well-optimized mobile
version whether you're using a tablet or
a phone into the breach Shines on these
smaller screens with its quirky pixel
art and freedom to plan every single
step you'll take in your turn if you
have a Netflix subscription it's an
essential download that'll keep you
entertained for weeks and months to come
in his 10 out of 10 review Chris Pereira
wrote into the breach is a game of
epiphanies and triumphs by limiting the
size of maps and the number of units and
actions you have it avoids ever becoming
overwhelming while still giving you a
wide enough possibility space that your
path forward is full of potential rather
than feeling preordained all of this
holds true in the new Netflix exclusive
mobile version which controls well and
never feels cramped even when played on
a much smaller screen than ever before
Point P offers maximum entertainment and
requires just a single digit of
interaction from you onwards and upwards
is the theme of this game as you Propel
your bounce happy protagonist through
cleverly designed levels in an attempt
to escape the gigantic more below you
that hungrily gobbles up anything of
nutritional value that falls into its
digestive Abyss to escape the blue Beast
all you need is a downward swipe that
propels your blob away from danger and
into some nearby fruit that will calm
the monster below you it's an easy to
learn mechanic that's also challenging
to master and with each level regularly
throwing new obstacles at you point P
remains a tense Race Against Time as you
climb toward the Finish Line it's
effortlessly charming and not too
demanding with its simple one-handed
gameplay making this fun and vibrant
puzzle platformer perfect for some cozy
gaming on a cold night in his 8 out of
10 review Kyle Hilliard wrote Point beat
represents my favorite kind of mobile
game dancing point B around is a simple
repeatable and function panic and I
never once had to think about currency
of any kind it can be played with one
hand and is both rewarding and
challenging without demanding too much
input from the player with its soft
ending it is clear this is not a game
you are expected to play Forever
those were gamespot's 5 best mobile
games of the year but there are plenty
more great games out there so here are 5
honorable mentions
dicey dungeons launched in 2019 but was
finally ported to Mobile in 2022. this
dice based roguelike from the creator of
Super Hexagon is a fast-paced delight
with a soundtrack that you simply won't
be able to get out of your head as one
of six giant dice it's up to you to
battle throughout a number of
procedurally generated Dungeons and
escape the clutches of Lady Luck
Streets of Rage 4 is nothing less than a
lovingly crafted beat-em-up that mixes
Rock Solid action with stunning art
Direction and a soundtrack that adds an
extra Touch of elegant violence to each
blow managing to fuse old and new school
sensibilities together this retro
comeback is easily digestible fun that
doesn't overstay its welcome
what happens when you mix dungeon
crawling with puzzles you get dungeons
of dreadlock a game that looks like it
was inspired by Game Boy Advance Legend
of Zelda titles with its visuals a
hundred dangerous basement levels await
you in this quirky descent with each
puzzle feeling like a well-designed
conundrum amidst some well-executed
action
the idea of being able to play Apex
Legends no matter where you are is a
heck of an elevator pitch and one that
respawn entertainment pulls off with
style bringing the core PC and console
experience to mobile Apex Legends on iOS
is a polished Showcase of Battle Royale
gameplay that raises the bar for the
genre on smaller screens constantly
evolving and updating this Standalone
game complements the bigger Apex Legends
experience with great design visuals and
competitive action
Sumaya won't grab your attention with
its by the books gameplay but it's the
delicate art Direction touching story
and stirring soundtrack that makes this
an essential purchase for iOS a tale of
dreams and the deceased sumai is a short
but captivating title that feels right
at home on mobile devices
so there you have it our picks for the
best mobile games of 2022 for our other
best of lists including best PlayStation
Xbox switch and PC games make sure to
check out gamespot.com or youtube.com
Gamespot thanks so much for watching and
I'll see you next time
[Music]